I'm at the Eureka weather station in
Nunavut in the Canadian High Arctic
about 80 degrees north here they provide
weather reports not just for the Arctic
but for the transatlantic flights high
above it because we're in none of it
there are three official languages here
English French and the local language
inducted to it although it's difficult
to be exact about languages in the
Arctic the line between dialects and
languages gets blurred people in
different areas can understand some of
what people say like most languages up
here in the Arctic and not to touch
means polysynthetic which means that
something that leads a whole sentence in
English can just be one long word with
each part affecting all the others now
in Greenland similar languages are
written using the Latin alphabet but the
words can seem unwieldy during the
speaker's the Latin alphabet is a
writing system that evolved for
completely different language one with
lots of short words and spaces but there
is an alternative it's used all around
northern Canada and to my eyes it's
really cool a bit of history the reason
this writing system exists is invented
by Christian missionaries who are trying
to spread the gospel the first books
printed in anak de toutes were extracts
from the Bible I've got some links in
the description to provide some context
there but there's no way I can cover
that in a short video that's mostly
about linguistics first up this is not
an alphabet in an alphabet vowels and
consonants both have letters which make
sense when you're speaking of language
with lots of complicated combinations of
sounds in it but it not like a lot of
polysynthetic languages has a relatively
simple syllable structure with rare
exceptions the maximum you can have in a
syllable is a consonant some vowels and
then another consonant that is it that
is all your options a long English one
syllable word like scratched wouldn't
work here you need to put vowels in
those constant pluses you need SEC care
radcheck long vowels being written with
two letters that's also additive long
words so the last alphabet gets a bit
overwhelmed but the inakute script is
not an alphabet it is an abugida each
symbol represents both a consonant and a
vowel the shape of the symbol tells you
the constant
the clever part the direction it's
pointing tells you the vowel I mean it's
got a dot above it it's long vowel like
R instead of app I'm not thing at the
vowels exactly right I'm English
and if there's a little symbol up
afterwards you add another constant at
the end so my name Tom would be like
this the curve shape means T let's point
you to the right which means the closest
you can get to an O here and the right
angle at the end means a closing em to
either accents different you might
transcribe it a little differently you
might flip the curve the other way Tam
and if you're American you would add a
little dot there for long vowel tan so
here is a simple word in Knox Chet and
Nana mother like almost every language
in the world
the word for mom is a sound that a baby
will make accidentally sorry parents is
probably an accent a triangle means no
consonant uh and pointed left always
means a simple our next step the shape
means either pointing left means ah and
the dot means long now and then the same
again without the dot now uh Nana the
word for father is a Tata
so swap the small route for the curve
the T from Tom there you go
a Tata and yes of course it's more
complicated than this
I am literally speaking baby talk but
compare this to the Latin alphabet well
they're just arbitrary symbols that you
have to learn I there's design here
there's intent there isn't complicated
letters with unwritten rules that all
influence each other this is an easy
script to learn and for an endangered
language there's only about 30,000
fluent speakers that is a really good
attribute and I'm here thanks to Chris
Hadfield generator arctic and so are
these Tim I am norm from tested Joey
from desert and we're here shooting a
bunch of educational videos as well you
can find those at youtube.com slash
tested calm links are in the description
or on screen now